hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll today
we're very fortunate to have an
extremely distinguished scientist
Antonio Damasio
is a well known neuroscientist and
professor of neuroscience at USC
University of Southern California here
in LA where he is also a professor of
psychology philosophy and neurology you
might remember that a few months ago we
talked to Lisa Aziz a day who also works
at USC in the brain and creativity
Institute and we talked about embodied
cognition the idea that what is
constituting our thoughts does not come
solely from our minds but also from our
bodies that our bodies have a role to
play in understanding how we think not
just what we do so Damacio is the
director of the brain creativity
Institute where this interview actually
took place and so he's been a pioneer in
this way of thinking for many many years
and in his new book which just came out
in paperback called the strange order of
things
he sort of summarizes what he's come to
think about this and he emphasizes
funnily enough the idea of feelings in
DiMaggio's view we don't take feelings
nearly seriously enough when we try to
explain how we think how we behave what
makes us human beings to demacia what a
feeling is is a way of our bodies
telling ourselves how we're doing with
respect to the goal of maintaining
homeostasis homeostasis is the condition
that our body is in when our temperature
is right our oxygen level is right and
so forth and feelings are somehow the
very very primal indications that we get
from our body that something is not
right or that everything is going really
really well so we actually trace
following his book the origin and
evolution of feelings from bacteria
which don't even have nervous systems
but they have sort of a precursor to the
idea of feelings all the way up through
evolutionary time to human beings and in
fact we go beyond that not just to
individual human beings but to societies
and cultures
Damacio tries to argue that the fact
that so much of who we are as human
beings is rooted in our feelings is
woefully new
acted when we think about the origin of
things like religion or politics or law
or anything like this any of the ways
that human beings get together in a
social context so I think both the
specific point of view that Damacio has
about these things and his love for
being synthetic and taking many many
different areas and mixing them together
and seeing how they interact with each
other is very similar to a point of view
that I took from a different angle in
the big picture in my own book so we had
a wonderfully sympathetic conversation
here and I think these are really ideas
that are both important and helpful as
well as little mind-bending so I think
this one you're gonna like let's go
[Music]
Antonio Damasio welcome to the mindscape
podcast my pleasure
so you've written several books but
we're gonna focus on your most recent
book and I think what I'd like to do is
sort of give away the punchline at the
beginning and then we can go back and
build up to it so as far as I can tell
the punchline is encapsulated in two
words feelings and homeostasis these
have very different you know vocabulary
word level of precision but tell us
about feelings why why is a
neuroscientist talking about feelings
this sounds like you know we're gonna
share our feelings with each other or
something like that there'll be nothing
wrong with that
no feelings is is actually a undeveloped
interest that people ought to have but
seem not to and it's a the kind of
phenomenon that has been completely
forgotten largely because of plain
cognition throughout the 20th century
and into our time we have given a
tremendous amount of attention to so
called cognitive phenomenon obviously
thinking processes the processes of
reasoning memory sensory processes as
well but people have forgotten that
there is something that from a point of
view of evolution precedes all of that
cognitive development and that has to do
with feeling with effect with the fact
that a living organism and especially a
living organism that is conscious and
has mental states has a constant
qualification of those mental states is
a favorable or unfavorable to life is
good or bad and and that's what we're
talking about when we talk about
affected about feelings and mind us you
know from reading the book feelings is
by no means a synonym of emotion on the
contrary you kid into two very important
concepts in the book feelings and
homeostasis
in neither of them is a synonym of
emotion emotion is the different things
that we can talk about so feelings is
indeed incredibly important phenomenon
is a phenomenon that I think only occurs
in creatures that have nervous systems
and minds you need to have both which
doesn't mean of course that it is
exclusively human not at all I expect
most creatures with a nervous system
that is complex enough and with a
complex body to have feelings if they
have feelings exactly like ours is a
different story but the the essence of
feeling is a positivity on negativity
something that we can describe with the
term valence and that has to do with how
the feeling state is conducive or not to
the continuation of life into the
quality of that life so valence
designates that quality so if it's not
just emotions so our emotions are
subsets of feelings or a kind of feeling
no emotions are as the name indicates
actions and that's part of the big
problems that has been so badly served
by the confusion of emotion and feeling
that is part of the of the culture of
any culture actually this is quite quite
widespread is that emotions are in fact
something that must have preceded
feelings and that consists of certain
actions that result in a better or worse
adaptation of a living creature to the
environment so when you when you have a
response by of some very simple organism
that consists of we drawing you could
say that that response is at heart an
emotive response so there is a movement
and that's that word emotion is in there
exact the word emotion is in there and
emotions such as we commonly know for
example fear
or the the motion of anger or compassion
are collections of actions that produce
a certain effect that resulted in
certain effect for the individual that
is undergoing the emotion and that
produces a certain effect outside in
other creatures or in the environment
but we all like to talk about emotions
as concerts of actions that the best
technical way of describing it is action
programs okay
whereas feeling and this is very simple
feelings are the experiences of those
action programs or going even deeper the
experience of the action programs that
enact life itself so when you tell me
that I feel so well and you are
describing well-being what I think you
are describing is your experience of
your organism functioning well
functioning in fact in something that if
not optimal is in the direction of the
optimal in terms of the way the
Armistice is being run inside your
organism and when you tell me that I
feel kind of sick what you're doing is
describing the collection of actions
it's integrated sense that you have that
your organism is having certain kinds of
actions that sort of describe life at
that moment and unfortunately it's not
going so well and it is on the basis of
all of this evolutionarily but then you
come to have these highly organized cons
little concerts this highly organized
acts of actions that we call emotions
most typically since it's so interesting
that people normally think of emotions
quite correctly from the great exemplars
they have around them for example fear
anger
disgusts happiness love exactly so they
go immediately to things that are
already highly organized and they don't
think that prior to that there were
already states of effect there were
already things that were good or bad for
example hunger thirst nervousness is
that a feelings no nervousness I would
say is it's both okay and by the way one
of the things that you realize is
happening here is that our language is
extremely limited or we end up having
the same word for the emotive set is for
the feeling itself or the mental
experience of having the emotive set so
when you say I'm happy you could be
describing the set of actions that
constitute your happiness which are
certain parameters of your metabolism
certain parameters of your musculature
you're smiling you're exactly certain
Beatitudes that you're having all of
which is motor you know it's motor all
the way down and motor all the way up
but you could be describing also this
feeling you have which is your mental
experience and so the feelings precede
the emotions I think maybe by mistake
you said earlier emotions precede well
it depends on what kind of feeling and
emotion you're talking about the the
very fundamental ones that I like to
call on me aesthetic feelings they
follow the actions of your state of
amused I see so it's probably better to
say that the actions always come first
okay and then and by the way that would
be in in keeping with the fact that in
the beginning it was action it was not
thinking you weren't thank you very much
when you're Assyrian you didn't have
exactly you didn't have minds what you
have is bodies and bodies act in your
bodies can make movements can sense
something can respond and responses
whenever we talk about responses we're
talking about one of two things either
something that is acted by a muscle or
something equivalent something that
allows an organism even a single-cell
organism
there's action or something that happens
internally which is the secretion or the
the release of a molecule that's an
action as well and in fact those are the
primordial action internal action it's
not one that we would see happening
example in action exactly okay and then
if things get more complicated and
eventually as you get nervous systems
and you can access to this United States
we call Minds then we have a variety of
experiences that are very complex and
that you can describe in relation to the
interior and in relation to the outside
and in some sense then the summary of
feelings is that they're a way for us to
recognize that we're deviating from this
homeostatic state so probably at this
point it would be good to tell our
listeners what homeostasis is and what's
so important about that exactly and I
think that one thing for for our
listeners it would be important to say
is that feelings follow-on amia stasis
the key thing in this whole story is of
course life and this this set of
characteristics that must be observed
for life to exist follows them persist
and of course homeostasis is a sort of
way of describing this rapidly is a way
of encapsulating all this and it
consists of a set of operations that do
a number of interesting things one is
maintain life so that it can continue
moment by moment so you're you're
running in essence to make it a little
bit more complicated you're running
metabolism you're using sources of
energy and you're using those sources of
energy to maintain a machine which is
made where it is one cell or many cells
in different tissues and organs doesn't
make any difference you need to feed
those cells with sources of energy and
you make this beautiful exchange that is
really the heart of what metabolism
is about it's really an exchange and and
you maintain cells alive and when you
have multiple cells they are integrated
in such a way that they realize certain
acts and they they sense what's around
which is important if they're going to
feed and they respond if you're coming
with a with a poke that could destroy an
organism so it's already from the get-go
a way of leading that organism into the
conditions that are essential for its
maintenance with the primary one of
which is the acquisition of sources of
energy in defending itself so you have
these two things you're not going to
continue living if you allow yourself to
be crushed and you're not going to
continue living if you don't have a way
of transforming a product external to
the organism into a source of energy so
that you maintain the machine going good
I mean there's two things that are that
are in here that I really want to tease
out before we get into the main part of
our conversation one of them is this
idea which I said myself in talks
homeostasis is a form of stasis in some
sense you know you can sit quietly
meditating not moving very much but it's
a very different kind than the table
being static and not exactly it's this
kind that requires constant upkeep and
this constant fuel injection and below
the surface there's a lot going on
absolutely it's really about activity
getting back to the idea that the reason
why emotion in motion are keys to what
we're talking about is that it's all
about activity it's you know better it's
very interesting you talk about it's
it's the last thing that it produces is
stasis but I think that the the the the
the source of the utilization of that
radical stasis is from the idea that
there's maintenance of something which
is in abstract the living condition but
it's not static at all it's constantly
activity and for me that the best
the best analogy is the analogy of the
wrong blur there is throwing ball
juggler we would say which is throwing
balls up in the air and it's constantly
having to be extremely precise about
where is going to be so that the ball so
and start falling because once one of
them starts falling then the rest will
follow in step but it's all about
activity and there's something that in
the juggler analogy you also capture is
how unnatural it is you see I think that
people of course we surround you by life
and it looks very natural well it really
isn't it's tiresome upkeep
it requires up keeping is an uphill
battle that's why it is so vulnerable
and that's why you need all sorts of
devices to keep it going and and of
course they are already extremely
powerful as a level of the single cell
and then they become incredibly powerful
when you're talking about
multicellularity even if you're talking
about a single insect let alone when
you're talking about a mammal such as we
are and then when you when you look at
the big creatures you realize something
else is that homeostasis again because
of that stasis root is very connected
with stability you know you have the
idea of something that is in balance but
it is not in balance and we will
constantly struggling about points it's
not that anja stasis is the balance
point in life no it's a range of
possibilities and within that range you
could then describe values that come out
of life in depth we have arbitrarily
given names such as goodness or badness
health and disease and you can you can
describe a level that is optimal or a
level that is so-so in ms mediocre but
there are all of these different levels
that are there in the process and it's
interesting because you know our
language at least
gives us most languages give us some
possibilities of describing this with
words such as for example well-being
well-being describes something that on
in the general distribution of states of
life goes towards towards where's the
good but something like flourishing
describe something even better more
dynamical more dynamic more rich more
expensive in the way it extrudes itself
from the organism and interacts with the
environment the malaise is one thing but
being sick with cancer is something else
for and there are all of these different
grades of homeostasis and of the
descriptor that we have in most
languages we have all of these marvelous
words to describe everything between you
know sickness and death and flourishing
and happiness on Twitter recently I said
that we won't ever get true human level
artificial intelligence until computers
can be bored and this is my sort of
cheeky way of pointing out you know you
turn on a computer it can just sit there
it doesn't feel the need to do anything
and this sort of the the role of
feelings and homeostasis in biological
life is an aspect which not only haven't
we but maybe we don't even try these
days to capture in that artificial
environment yeah I think you're
absolutely right
and I think that one of the one of the
the problems with artificial
intelligence is the way it has been
conceived very artificially thinking
about organisms quote-unquote that are
made of rigid materials materials that
don't bend materials that have a minimum
of vulnerability and that is exactly the
opposite of what life is all about it's
not this constant turning no mean life
life is about the vulnerability and the
dragwon trying to keep this thing which
is the most unnatural you can imagine
and the artificial for example when you
think of most of the robots that one can
think of as intelligent and very
successful
there are things that are you know you
can destroy them with an axe in by real
act of violence but they will not get
sick the heard that don't they get bored
don't get sick either and what are they
very happy
you know you the Roomba that cleans your
floor is not going to be happier as a
result of doing a good cleaning job and
and showing on that point this was
something interesting so we're very
interested in in that in that issue
because I think there's a way in which
the problems of feeling the whole issue
of feeling can be brought into robotics
into artificial intelligence in general
and there's there's an interesting
development that has to do with soft
robotics which I'm sure you're aware of
and that has to do with materials that
emulate a little bit some of the
properties of living things such as for
example movements there are such a
movement over Cyclops and with materials
that band as opposed to materially no
arms that are made of rigid parts
articulated in the most comical fashion
possible when you compare them with the
way a limp in muscles really operate and
I think that the a lot of that still
does not aim at the the the critical
issue of feeling the the critical issue
of feeling potentially can be dealt with
if we develop designs of robotics in
which we have that vulnerability in
other words trying to solve the problem
in in a way that looks illogical because
instead of trying to create a machine
that is super robust you know the logic
if you're going to do something that in
any way emulates life is to make it
vulnerable and also the ability to then
repair itself when that vulnerability
takes place exactly and in South Africa
of course we are very far from from that
but I think it's a very important idea
and actually here at the the BCI
we have an interest in that we have been
talking about this and one of my young
colleagues Kingston man is actually
working on that problem and we think
that you know it deserves attention also
it's very interesting because the
community is more receptive to it now
I'm getting there yeah yeah I remember
the first times that I talked in public
a little bit like you and I said look
you're not serious about about
conferring feelings or any kind of
useful mind truly intelligent mind to a
device such as yours and people would be
extremely offended and probably I was
not doing it the right way either but
now people have become very receptive
and we've had numerous instances in
which people say oh well you're
absolutely right that makes sense and I
think it also comes from the fact that
people are now more ready to accept
homeostasis is a very important part of
what we are as living creatures and
feelings is a very good proxy
once you have nervous systems and minds
which of course are late developments in
the history of language but this is part
of your bigger message which is I mean
when we're talking about area eyes and
robot that when you're thinking about
what minds are you can't separate them
from bodies they came from bodies they
still are embedded but actually and that
needs to be taken into account exactly
and and a lot of what you know it's very
interesting too there are all sorts of
you know almost each one of these topics
could be a topic for one of your
programs you know
but just think of the fact that when you
have a mind you normally think of it is
unconnected to a body and you think of
it now especially after the huge success
of the the past's hundred years of
biology and science you think of it as
in relation to the nervous system alone
now this is very very wrong in other
words not the rest of the body not just
of the nerve and and one of
one of the points that I'm trying to
make with the strange heart of things
and why there is the words order and
strangeness in the title is that it
didn't begin that way it didn't be you
know we've had life on on earth for most
of the existence of life long this long
history which is I mean almost four
billion years and we've have we have had
nervous systems perhaps for 500 million
this is a pittance in most of that time
we had extremely complex living
creatures first without many nucleus
even single cells no nucleus membrane
but then with with the nucleus in then
multicellularity and then an accretion
of systems such as for example the
endocrine system the immune system
circulation all of these things preceded
the appearance of nervous systems and
guess what they were conferring even
with that so-called simplicity which is
nothing like simple and they were
conferring on those creatures a
possibility of extremely intelligent
behavior and that allow them to
socialize or not socialize a lot of them
independence if the energy around was
sufficient to maintain that life or
allow them to create alliances with
others like-minded except there was my
party affiliation exactly party
affiliation and allow them to fight what
to do incredible things such as
pretending that there's no conflict and
moving away into another side in other
words you have this single-cell
creatures that behave for eons in ways
that if you were describing them without
saying it was a single-cell creature and
you were simply making a notation some
of sociological notation of the
attitudes of the creature you would
immediately atribute them intentions or
mind purposes and all of those things
well they do have purposes they do have
intentions except that they are not
expressed the way your intentions of
mine are expressed which is through a
thinking process in which we identify a
goal and we try to execute that code
because we have a mind and we have that
man because we developed at certain
point and nervous system but all of
these are sort of light developments and
we have this huge spectacular history of
life with intentions with presumed
purposes protecting life through and
through because that becomes the purpose
well and I unspoken purpose and and but
that was all there prior to nervous
systems and minds and part of the role
part of the usefulness in telling that
story is a slightly deflationary role in
the sense that when we think of
ourselves and we think about feelings
and consciousness and other things like
that it's just hard for us to imagine
that this is purely mechanical right and
there's plenty of our colleagues who
give in to the temptation to assign
something non mechanical non
materialistic non-physical to it but if
but if you dig back into the
evolutionary history you see precursors
of everything and so I love I mean maybe
you couldn't even go into a little bit
more detail about specifically bacteria
and how they act I mean bacteria are
pretty much the most primitive organisms
that we have around there's no there are
single cells they don't even have a
nucleus but like you said they team up
and this is true even a bacteria today
and was presumably true of bacteria
billions of years ago yeah exactly yeah
and they and a team they they have a
very rich social life and that social
life can depending on the environment
see all this again the the pushes push
pushes us into this core issue of life
management in homeostasis so for example
if they are in a terrain that is
extremely fertile and that offers
sources of energy galore bacteria
actually live there independently they
can be isolated but if introverts the
introvert but if they are in the
situation of scarcity if there's not
enough feed
material or if they are under threat
then they will group together and they
they form a coalition that allows them
to defend themselves and they they do
that for example the kind of bacteria
that can attack your throat or mine and
and give us a very enjoy us for example
like doing exactly the same thing they
will go into that terrain they are on an
aggressive mode and they want to feed
off your tissues our living tissues and
then of course it's going to provoke a
reaction and with our organism is going
to try to defend itself against them and
then they bacteria are going to try to
defend themselves against the defense of
our organism and they can for example
form a palisade and produce a chemical
substances that will isolate them from
the actions of our organism or the
actions of antibiotics that we may take
so that all of this game is being played
by these little creatures that you
cannot see without a microscope and they
don't have a cell but they'd have a life
to defend come what may even if they
don't know they have a life and and
probably none of us would say that in
some sense even if this is a valid
formulation that the bacteria truly have
intentions planning desires or whatever
but the point I think the point is that
when you look at how they actually
behave you see the behaviors that later
evolved into intestine to second so it
there is something very beautiful in the
fact that the this plan of lives the
weights it operates is organized
contains these devices these strategies
and all of those strategies then become
more expressed as you have a
multicellular body and as you have for
reasons that have to do with
multicellularity a controller because
you see that the the the the reasons why
you end up having a nervous system is
that as you as your body grows bigger
in a multicellular way what was very
easy to control in terms of the release
of a chemical molecule that would
diffuse and with you know be sort of
noted everywhere in that little body now
becomes very difficult to exert that
control because you no longer can expand
that all over a bigger organism so you
have a nervous system and the nervous
system is helping you control the stuff
is helping you
for example coordinate the the motility
in this is helping you put a certain
sector working in a certain way once you
develop say something like a heart
beating that needs to to the propulsion
of blood in inside inside a tubular
structure so all of these things are
constantly being developed with a logic
and that logic is the logic of life and
of course the way it operates
evolutionarily is another story but it
is as if you could constantly tell the
story in this look you're gonna have
single creatures with life no nucleus
then you give them a nucleus story gets
more complicated then you give them
multicellularity then you give them a
nervous system to help with
multicellularity otherwise you can't
cope with that and then eventually you
come to this very beautiful and
unexpected development which is the
possibility of creating maps of what is
going on within the structure or within
a body and of what is going on outside
and that's the three merchants of minds
and it's very beautiful because on the
developer on the side which has to do
with the interior where you make maps of
what is going on inside your body that's
the line that is going to lead you
towards feeling whereas the side that
looks at what is outside and uses eyes
or ears to pick up on sounds or the
morphology of structures that's
something that gives you
access to the exterior but but those are
exactly the same things that you and I
have in our organism except we have it
with an enormous wealth that more every
creature does but but but that that
duality what goes to the inside in what
comes to the outside is very critical
and maybe but maybe you don't want to go
there but go there tell about the things
that have to do with the interior that
are fabulously fabulously beautiful so
well probably the most important for for
your listeners is is the fact that when
you think if you ask two men on the
street or any of our colleagues there is
not thought about this problem said
where do minds come from the person will
say well brains obviously we cannot have
minds without brains that sounds you
know logical enough and I've just stated
many times when I was talking about the
emergence of minds the issue is that
although brains are essential for the
making of minds as we know them it
doesn't follow that all the aspects of
mind
come exclusively from nervous systems
and here we enter a realm that is
absolutely central to current day
neuroscience and to philosophy of mind
is that we have been in a very bad very
bad way attributing minds exclusively to
nervous systems to the point that people
will say well you have minds because you
have chains of neurons firing using
synapses and that's of course where
Minds come from we call it neuroscience
exactly and people are very happy with
this well it's not as easy as that
because when you look at this huge world
of affect the world of feeling and the
emotions that can be associated with
you actually realize that this is not
being generated primarily out of the
nervous system but with the
participation of the nervous system
where the stuff is coming from is guess
what your body is your muscles the
whether this a striated muscle with
which you can move an arm or the smooth
muscles which is which are around blood
vessels and which can be tight or loose
but are absolutely critical to the
maintenance of an organism and what is
being imaged mentally in relation to
effect is actually those phenomena that
have to do with the body so when you
think about feeling when you think about
feeling anxious for example when you
think about feeling very relaxed and
happy what you are describing or but but
what you are experiencing is actually a
state of the body that is being
described mentally thanks to a coalition
of your body structures and your nervous
structures and it's the two together
that are creating the foundation of mind
which is your state of affect of course
we have a totally inverted things in the
20th century by going you know
completely crazily into a cognitive
track ignoring feeling and emotion and
thinking about thinking as if it were
the true substance of mind as if we were
brains and that's exactly right and you
had the synapses and fire and so forth
and this is crazy and many in many ways
first of all it totally denies the
reality that we're dealing with in the
partnership of bodies and nervous
systems but then it also does something
else is that the nervous system by and
large does not work only in the way that
is
even the typical brain in the vet
scenario our brains are whenever systems
are quite synaptic no no question about
it but then there's this huge world of
non synaptic transmission and contacts
which uses different rules so when you
have the typical textbook neurons and
synapse you have an axon that connects
via synapse to another neuron and that
action in the most advanced form is
myelinated so that action has been
insulated so that it doesn't leak
current and is actually protected from
the influences of the the perineural
space when you go to the interoceptive
system that's the system that brings
into your central nervous system signals
that have to do with your skin with your
interior with the the the organs with
your gut hum or all of that stuff that
comes via spinal ganglia and that comes
via nerves such as the vagus nerve all
of those all of those neurons are not
myelinated so they are not insulated and
they are open to the vagaries of the
surround they're listening to their
environment they're listening to their
environment and so they are all of these
molecules that can have an influence so
yes this neuron is eventually going to
fire but it's not going to fire in the
same predictable way that the neuron
that was insulated will do it so it's
going to be different it's going to be
modulated by the environment and by the
way this is this is not a small amount
of nervous this is probably the majority
of neurons in our nervous system operate
this way not only that the spinal
ganglia which come all on the spine you
have this ganglion with a bunch of cell
bodies those ganglia including our
trigeminal ganglion which has everything
is to do with our head not an important
part of our body all of that is open in
terms of blood-brain barrier so instead
of having a blood-brain barrier which
selectively stops molecules from
crossing and entering the central
nervous system on the contrary it's open
which means that the stuff that is
circulating what you're taking what you
have been drinking or what you have been
taking is going to have an influence on
over how that operates which really
means that not only do you have this
huge participation of the body in the
operations of mind but even the nervous
system transmission of signals from one
to the other is influenced by the state
of the body so it's a it's a very
complicated picture that is nothing to
do with the brain on event let's put it
this way but it's part of our prejudice
you know that it's the thinking
cognitive conscious part of our brain
that is coming up with these schemes and
your prejudices it puts itself at the
top right exactly yeah but I think that
the in in by the way one of the big
difficulties on the issue of
consciousness which we can all agree has
become one of the most popular topics in
neuroscience and psychology and
currently science in general is that the
conception that you have of how minds
are made by nervous systems or by bodies
in general is going to influence the way
you think about consciousness and and I
think that by and large the the the
traditional views have not been
favorable to it or to a clear view of
what what we we have in front of us and
I think that you know it's maybe a
little bit offensive to some people but
I think that the problem is far simpler
then it's normally taken I'm not saying
it's simple I'm just saying that the
idea of a heart problem that you cannot
transpose I think it's wrong I did have
as a previous podcast guest we had David
Chalmers on the podcast who is the
champion of the hard problem of
consciousness separating out the easy
problems of action and perception from
the hard problem of inner experience
right
and I noticed that in your book you take
two pages to solve the hard problem
of consciousness and then move on that's
right that's that's what it deserves no
no I'm not going to I'm not going to
joke a party because it's it's it's more
serious than that the reason why it's is
the the section on consciousness
actually became much smaller in the book
is that I I had decided quite some time
ago to write something on consciousness
alone and and then there was so much on
consciousness that it unbalanced the
both the book is about the strange order
of developments in in in biology in
general in relation to a mysticism
feeling not about conscious although all
of this story stasis in feeling is
absolutely critical for for
consciousness well I was going to say if
I understood those two pages I mean I I
think that the efforts whether were
there ten don't know they said the hard
problem I think it was only oh ok very
good maybe but III thought it was I'm
also not that convinced that the hard
problem is a true problem we're gonna be
struggling with for many years and I
think that what you but but then if I
were channeling David Chalmers here as
in my role is the podcast host he would
say but you know there's some
fundamental difference between how we
act in the world you know are
objectively seen motions and and
statements versus our inner experience
and what you try to be seen seem to be
saying is that look if you just look at
evolution and you just look at the
existence of feelings trying to maintain
homeostasis you would naturally find if
you were smart enough that it makes
sense for organisms to develop the
properties of having inner experience is
that a fair way to say it's absolutely
yeah and and I think that you you do
develop is things that for example are
very interesting in that are not clear
is at which point consciousness
developed for example the relation
between consciousness and feeling is
it's so tight that one could say that
and well definitely you cannot have one
without the other you cannot have a
conscious or
organisms there would not be at the same
time a feeling organism and nothing
interesting that I can say is that when
you tell me that you have a certain
feeling you tell me that because you're
conscious if you were not conscious you
could not tell me that so the two things
are completely associated and I think
that if I would have to venture this
exact way it began it began first out of
necessity because feeling being the
representative of homeostasis is the
critical issue that needs to be to be a
guide needs to be the rather for how
we're going to continue life and and
then it made sense and it was good and
obviously was selected because it was so
so favorable evolutionarily it made
sense for us to know that that was
happening because what by the way and
shown you you may want to point your
listens to the fact that so what a good
part of the history of discussions on
feeling especially in the 20th century
people used to say monstrous things such
as it's useless they're useless you know
it's something that you can do without I
mean I don't you want to be smart you
want to speak well represent well in
words what you have thought abstractly
and do equations do the math right
creates new objects to all of these
things but feelings are so we are
necessary in the middle of all this
forgetting the fact that you would not
have done any interesting thing if you
did not have feelings to protect your
life go to invigorate you to pursue a
certain goal then you extract feelings
from the machine and the machine stops
there's nothing why why continue this
sounds like a very American perspective
this feelings don't matter kind of thing
you said that your book was more popular
in Europe and in the US well yeah yeah I
don't know if there would be other
reasons for that but anyway yes it could
be I think that it's certainly an
attitude that has come from the huge
says of a number of Sciences and the
huge success of the I mean the the
realization that complex thinking is of
course the way into great science and
technology I mean you you're not going
to do science and technology with
feeling alone but you're not going to do
good science and technology without
really not gonna be interested in doing
any of it right the physicist in me
thinks of this evolutionary history you
sketched out is a series of phase
transitions right from non-life to life
and then to eukaryotic life with cells
than multicellular life and you
mentioned the importance of images
internal images like so where does it so
we have images of both ourselves and the
outside world inside of us inside of our
brains does that happen do we develop
that gradually or does that sort of
appear on the scene at some point that
capability both it had to appear at a
certain point the possibility of image
in in by the ways it's best talking
about images talk about maps because
that sort of cues people into the idea
of how it could be made a relationship
yeah it's a relationship it's it's
really mapping it's it's it's plotting
something in terms of another material
in terms of another medium so I can plot
what's on that wall
by making a sketch that has those frames
of those pictures it's that idea and you
can do this whether it's the visual
which is of course the easy one to
explain but you can do this in relation
to what you touch can you see in
relation to what you hear and when you
comes to smell and taste you do this in
terms of the consequences of certain
molecules that that you are that you are
processing but their mapping function
appeared of course it required nervous
systems because we didn't there didn't
have nervous systems you would not have
the it wouldn't have the paper to create
the copy right you needed you needed the
substrates to store the information
exists to solve it to tooten to depict
it and enter into eventually to store it
in memory so nervous systems are key
but the nervous systems probably started
doing a dual a dual mapping of certain
things in the outside that were very
important and certain things inside that
were also important and those happen to
be you know just not very beautiful
perhaps in the guts so you know and
that's why the the you know there's this
discussion very often people talk about
the gut is of the second brain and and
and that's pretty comical because it was
the first chronologically it was that is
the first into this you know at first we
were sort of floating digestive systems
and you had a gut in the nervous system
was there to create peristalsis to give
action so that but of course at the same
time if you have digestion you were
having digestion of something that you
ate and in order for you to eat you
better have some sense of where the
thing that you're going to eat was and
that comes from the sensing of the
outside so it's probably co-developed
the internal the internal mapping and
the external mapping and of course but
still still with us today and it not
it's not by chance that so many of the
feelings you have actually relate to the
gut yeah for example anxiety you know a
lot of them fundamental expressions you
have to do with that what happens in the
garden so it's highly conserved and you
can imagine that non-human creatures
probably have something quite similar
the other is of course respiration
because a lot of our a lot of feelings
that have to do with our well-being are
tied to the kind of airflow you have
does the air flow easily what is it
constricted right and but again all of
those things are and autonomic control
you know you don't you don't tell your
your bronchi to constrict and give you
an attack of asthma they do if the right
molecules are there do you ever read um
de lama trees manna machine oh yes me
many many I bet I can't promise you that
I read the whole thing but I there was a
time
yeah I my dick hard time I taught I
taught a course at the University of
Chicago for undergraduates on the
history of atheism and elementary was
one of the first people to come out in
public as a self-proclaimed atheist and
it's funny that he names his book man a
machine because in fact he puts a lot of
emphasis on the body and he says look
I'm a different person when I've had
coffee you know I've not had coffee how
can you possibly think my mind is
separate from my body there were plenty
of smart cookies then that's right and
but okay so now half an hour ago I said
there were two aspects of homeostasis I
wanted to tease out we've got one of
them the other is this future
directedness of it so I think that
people can would think of homeostasis if
they looked it up in the dictionary as
maintaining some features you know
maintaining our existence within this
controlled set of parameters where we
can flourish but you have this extra
aspect that was almost teleological that
is sort of planning for the future was
that how did that come in was that
always there is that a late development
on the scene in terms of evolution yeah
or in terms of my thinking in terms of
my thinking it came it came late but
what's so interesting in this why it's
so important not to describe how many
stasis is just balanced so again it's
it's a range of possible states that are
compatible with life but then there's
this aspect that has to do with the in a
way you could call it and we could force
yourself into calling it a prediction
but it's a sort of internal knowledge
non-explicit internal knowledge that you
there are certain conditions under which
you're likely to go under you're likely
not be salvageable and that you need to
protect yourself for such conditions and
one of the easy ways to protect yourself
in these circumstances is
to horde up material that is essential
as energy supply so there's one of the
reasons why it's so obvious that people
are not the the homeostatic machine is
not just giving you the say the thirst
of the hunger for a certain amount of
food and then you stop now it actually
lets you overeat or over drink so that
you can have some stores for the rainy
day and they come in handy and bother
it's interesting that from a general
human point of view it's so interesting
that people who have very severe diets
and who actually do something quite
unnatural which is not eat anything and
go into a state of enormous thinness
those people are actually vulnerable to
diseases there are other resources yeah
exactly so we need some of those
resources we don't need to be fat but we
need to have fat stores for example for
the moments in which you have a disease
because when you have a disease you
really have a huge consumption of those
of those products and if you don't have
them you go under and so that's that's
one part that is to do with with the
future and then of course you have the
the constant for creatures that are
thinking you have the constant
utilization of states of feeling by best
experience to allow you to construct a
better future where you will not fall
into the dangers you've felt before and
so forth so that's where assist a
primary feeling system can give goods to
a thinking system and again it's so
important because without those guides
without the fact that you not only have
experienced pain and have experienced as
a hunger but you have reflected on it
because you stored that memory and you
you have had the possibility of bringing
it back and you have the possibility of
having certain warning signs that will
bring that memory back
and within that's what is constantly
playing in you to correct your behaviors
that's why it's inconceivable that you
can have a social life in the ample
sense of the term if you were not guided
by feelings of every character the the
feelings that have to do with you for
example having been loved or having been
ostracized all of those things are going
to that there were experience there
memorized as effect not as a feeling
because interestingly we don't make
memories of feelings scratch but really
yeah it's quite interesting just thing
if you if you made memories of all the
pains you have suffered for one thing
there would be no childbirth you never
read a book but so you you you don't
actually make memories of the expen
mental experience of suffering or of joy
for that matter what you do is maintain
a number of commentaries on those things
and then you can reactivate by something
I call the as if body loop you can
reactivate some semblance of the state
you've lived through but it's this
interplay that that of course involves
not just feeling but but thinking about
feeling and memory that is what is
guiding a lot of our a lot of our
activity and and of course that's the
kind of thing that allowed the creation
of cultures yeah so good it's exactly
what I wanted to get to I mean we're
already being pretty ambitious going
from bacteria to us and consciousness
and the whole thing guided by this
interplay of homeostasis and feeling but
you you correctly I think point out
there's also a story to be told about
how we become social and how we talk to
each other and how we develop culture
yeah yeah how we develop all these
instruments that again with with with
the typical a lack of concern for the
feeling component of humanity people
attribute just to great thinking some
we're very smart people
and we reason beautifully and that's why
we're developing moral systems come on
we just don't know you develop moral
systems because we are naturally
informed of things that are good for you
and compatible with happiness and you
also develop the knowledge that they are
good for other people so you have the
guide with the primitives the the
originals that are going to shape what
is your moral behavior are coming out of
your knowledge sometimes without paying
too much attention to it of what it is
to experience life to suffer and to be
you know ecstatically happy and you
either want other people to have that or
you don't want to make them suffer but
but all of that comes out of that core
information so the the way we develop
moral in by the way religious systems
that would come from the same tissue
from the same set of phenomena and the
way we do out of that systems of justice
the way we create for example systems of
governance systems that include
economics and diplomacy and so forth all
of that comes out of this core of
feeling reasoned through an intelligent
system so once again we are in this sort
of apparent dilemma which is not that
you cannot do any of this without
thinking you cannot do any of this you
know in a complex way without language
to express that thinking but nor can you
do it without feeling the two things
have to be together if you just have
feeling you're obviously not going to
become a moral philosopher but if you
are very very smart and not feeling you
better not be a born philosopher are you
gonna be awful is this I mean the
reflection of David Hume saying reason
should be the slave of the passions well
I think David you was a brilliant
thinker on exactly the same note yeah
you know I think he's one of the people
that I very much
respect and there's some people are
severe owes of mine and because they got
it when they might not because the
knowledge wasn't there you means is one
of them Spinoza is another in very
different reactions Spinoza problem is
that most the most unexpected and
profound because it's so simple but the
guy got it he realized what was life he
realized through this this idea of the
the conatus
the the forces that were impelling life
in a certain direction so he of course
he didn't have the word omnia stasis but
he was describing all of this he was
describing life conditions that are good
or not so good he was describing a route
for a moral behavior in these
fundamental conditions and you know it's
quite brilliant putting it all in terms
of moral systems and philosophy of
action in the world and so forth Spinoza
seems like one of those philosophers who
is often neglected or forgotten but
there's always a whole bunch of people
saying you shouldn't forget this guy
like he actually had a lot figured out
you are quite right no and especially in
in in the American tradition Spinoza is
very much ignored so yappy knows is
throwing through a European philosopher
and I remember when I wrote my my book
about about Spinoza and it's a book
called looking for Spinoza and I got one
review by philosophy philosopher
reviewer that shall be nameless who said
that I had written a book about a minor
some something quite not only was he not
terribly appreciative of my word it was
even he wasn't less kind to it was a
minor philosophy well you know the times
the times change so if I if I want to
push back a little bit I mean sure we're
we're organisms we want to maintain
homeostasis we've developed this
capability in our minds to have maps and
images of the future and plan and be
social but does that
would Karl Popper worry if we were here
that this is too good to be true we can
explain everything you do talk about
religion a little bit in your book and
you say well on one hand religion has
some aspects that help us have good
feelings and maintain homeostasis on the
other hand it has some aspects that make
us feel bad and get into Wars and people
are oppressed are we are we still
reaching for more explainatory precision
here or is this what we can hope for no
I think we can get much more precision I
think obviously you want to have more
precision in the description of the
phenomena themselves in in how they have
for example phenomenon feeling have
acquired the power that they have but
there's something that I think answers
your your question which has to do the
enormous confusion under which we are
when we don't make clear distinctions
between both feelings and emotions there
are positive versus negative for example
it's quite typical for you to read some
politician or some you know pundit that
says well we have to be rational
individuals we know how to think and the
last thing we want is to give this to
too emotional to become too emotional
I mean how many times a week do you read
in the main newspapers that certain bad
things happen because people are being
too emotional the curious thing is that
every time that people make that
accusation they are referring to
negative emotions should be too joyful
yeah but so the body is claiming that
you are getting into all these problems
because of being over joyful and hopeful
for the world and being magnanimous in
being full of generosity or compassion
or admiration for others well those are
emotions in the respective feelings in
those constitute a huge amount of what
our effective life is what we do have
though is fear
and anger in spite and contempt and many
other thing in Pride and all of these
things which other ones that get us into
Wars and into conflicts that are tragic
he serve uses as well and they serve
uses and of course they are there that
were concerned because guess what we we
were saved evolutionarily by tons of
fear and buy tons of anger because if we
didn't have the fear we would have been
eaten by some other creature or killed
and if we didn't have anger we would
have been killed by the guy who had the
bigger gun so they were useful but the
questions that they're not useful all
the time you need to you need to know
the time at which you should use those
because you are under the control of
reason so the the the the idea that well
you you have these problems because your
being over emotional is silly you you
have the problems because you can use
the wrong emotions and you use the wrong
emotions if you don't have a layer of
control over your emotional apparatus
that comes out of reason comes out of
thinking comes out of information sheer
knowledge that says no that's stupid
done to it and that's where you can get
the the combination of the two
I had a Paul bloom on the podcast and
earlier and he wrote this wonderful
titled book called against empathy and
his argument I if I can sort of
cartoonishly summarize it was you know
we tend to empathize with empathy sounds
good but we empathize with people like
ourselves and instead of doing that we
should be rational about morality and
how to behave and so forth and you know
I tried to argue against him number one
that you know that he agreed actually
with the first one which is your initial
motivation to be rational has to come
from somewhere right to be moral has to
come from somewhere but number two I
thought that you know that's if you're
just being empathetic with people like
yourself that might be a natural trap to
fall into but the result but the but the
diagnosis shouldn't be you have too much
empathy is that you're doing empathy
wrong then you should try to train
yourself to be empathetic we people
unlike
yourself because otherwise you will
think you're being rational but you will
discount their experience absolutely I
entirely agree with you and I think that
that it comes to to the point that
thanks to our reasoning abilities and
thanks to our knowledge we have
possibilities of shaping and controlling
the affective system not to suppress the
effects in fact you see but use it
better and use it well intelligently
right yeah it's a give and take yeah and
it's not the this dismissal of of
emotion is something irrational is just
silly because a lot of the time a lot of
the time it isn't and even if it were
irrational in some affinity it is
irrational in some circumstances there's
no reason why you should not strive for
doing better in doing it and irrational
control so it's not to do reason instead
of emotional feeling is to use reason to
control to select and control the most
appropriate emotional and the most
appropriate affective response and and I
think that's an entirely different world
yeah yeah so good that's that I mean
sort of leads me into my final question
we've already talked a little bit about
the implications at this point of view
for artificial intelligence and we also
talked about how this point of view
helps explain and account for the
emergence of culture and so forth what
are the lessons for culture and society
going forward from this understanding of
why we have culture and society in the
first place I mean we're at a point in
our human history as liberal democracies
and so forth where nerves are frayed
where people are feeling anxious there's
a lot of debates which are carried out
at a very superficial level but have I
think deeper residents about identity
who belongs in our culture you know who
we should support who's on our tribe
who's on our team is there something
that you know some bit of wisdom or
maybe just some some practical advice
for guiding our society once we have
this better understanding of why we have
society in the first place that's an
excellent question
I think that
they probably that the best message is
look we know a little bit more about how
we function in this schism between a
rational creature or an effective
creature is false this is fiction this
is does not accord with our nature and
then try to learn as much as possible
about how your nature functions for
example in the kind of conflicts that
you are referring to so typical now
especially with thee with the enormous
power of social media what what we need
is to diffuse the knee-jerk reaction
that is caused by giving in to the very
easy provocation of anger or fear
especially anger that there's something
about the the reactions of anger in
there they manipulate it beautifully by
political systems so that you know if
there's something that you want achieved
make sure that people will go for it
with anger and generally against some
cause or kind of person and and so I
think that knowing how this works from
the inside
having no illusions about the fact that
we're either just purely smart people
you know theoretical physicists that's
my example oh no they were just bad
people with with with bad emotions just
it's more complicated than that and try
to to move forward by having one
influence the other now it's not easy
and I don't think that you know I'm most
of the time these days I'm more
pessimistic than optimistic about having
a great success come out of our
struggles but we're certainly not going
to give to have any success if we don't
realize what we are
humanly in general in terms of our life
in and this peculiar thing that is
having a mind in a very complex living
creature
and starting with that with a little bit
of humility is probably the best I mean
going making it more local bringing you
down because we can't always affect the
world but do you think that the way you
live your life has been importantly
colored by this way of thinking about
what a mind is never thought about that
um I guess so I guess so yes I would say
so and if there's certain choices that
I've made that we're probably influenced
by that well that's good advice for then
people listening to buy the book and
maybe they'll maybe they'll make better
informed choices all right Antonio
Damasio thanks so much for being on the
podcast Thank You Sean thank you
[Music]